un martinique tech nous avons décidé de
nous mobiliser et de mettre à
disposition nos compétences gratuitement
et bénévolement pour pouvoir accompagner
donc toutes les entreprises à mieux
utiliser le digital dans cette période
de crise sanitaire
donc nous avons lancé l'initiative les
assauts des digital ce sont des
webinaires des conférences en ligne
on parle vous pouvez accéder de manière
très simple grâce à votre téléphone
votre ordinateur ou votre tablette
comment faire vous vous inscrivez sur le
site de marc ligny tech vous choisissez
le ou les webinaires que vous intéresse
et vous y assister et vous pouvez les
retrouver ensuite en replay c'est très
facile
nous sommes très satisfaits parce que
nous avons lancé de manière complètement
instantanée la semaine dernière cette
initiative et nous avons compris qu'elle
répond à une demande
parce que nous avons des participations
et une adhésion forte
nous avons des gens qui se sont inscrits
de la martinique
bien évidemment mais également de
bordeaux de haïti et donc nous
poursuivons donc cette campagne autant
que nécessaire et vous pourrez retrouver
la programmation chaque semaine sur le
site de martine tech